I'm not sure how much,
uh,
what I wish men knew about women that
they don't,
I think it's,
I think men can do a better job of
really listening to women.
I think a lot of times,
you know,
there's an old Chinese saying called
Tang,
um,
I think I'm getting this right.
And it means to listen with your heart,
your ear and your mind.
And I think sometimes when people
listen,
they,
they don't listen with their full
selves.
You know,
this is what emotional intelligence is
all about.
I think women give a lot of,
you know,
set something like 70% of communication
is nonverbal.
And that can be completely irrational to
some people.
Like,
tell me exactly what you want to say.
So I think if men would listen with
their heads,
heart,
and mind altogether,
I think they'd have better relationships
with,
you know,
their,
their partners,
their mother's,
whoever it is.
But I also think that the world would be
a much better place.